- Is it true that you're also
a video game character now?
I mean, I think you've made it when you're
a video game character.
- Yeah you've arrived.
- I'm just saying.
- This is it,
this is my last public appearance
and that's it.
- This is my real question.
And you have to be,
(audience cheering)
you have to be honest.
Have you ever played yourself in the game?
Like you're-
- Yes.
- Okay, I was like, don't lie.
- Yes, yes.
- I would play me, I'd
be like, I'm killing it.
- He's also really good as well.
So he's like, I just give
the ball to him all the time.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- There was a time when my
girlfriend came back home
and I mean, it puts a
whole different meaning
to her finding you playing with yourself,
but it's with myself.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
And she came back.
(all laughing)
- So your girlfriend came in.
- She was like, "Not again".
(all laughing)
- Yeah, it's rather embarrassing.
- Oh my, and there's nothing
worse than that bust.
I mean.
(all laughing)
(all laughing audience clapping)
Nothing worse.
- I love this (inaudible).
- I mean, my children have caught me
watching old sketches of mine
howling and laughing
and at myself, nothing.
- The good days.
- It's humiliating.
- Oh my God.
It's awesome.
Watching your own video.
- I still watch it.
- They're like, you can start it over.
Mortified.
- You know what?
You missed this part.
- Yeah, yeah.
Look, come watch this,
this is the best bit.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.